[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh maman
alors là j'ai un jour majeure fabrice
bonjour tout cas encore baby gym matin
je suis content mais je suis perplexe
donc ouais bah ça chantait pondu un jeu
aujourd'hui eh bien oui
en réalité je vois un oeuf dhabhawi
tiendront aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
bonjour dit bonjour gentiment au jeu
mieux que ça ben on joue à la règle
bonjour à tous et à toutes
suivez ce que nous a préparés tout
content parce que ça m'a l'air assez
délirant alors c'est quoi cette affaire
là avec s'étoffe
est ce que je fais l'oeuf mystérieux
l'oeuf esclaves
c'est un bluff oui c'est l'oeuf esclaves
oui pour nous on fait ce qu'on en veut
s'engager d'avoir alors qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire et battu le pose sur le petit
tu vois tu le pose sur le petit côté
pointu temps précieux points aux bleus
puis tu vas voir ce qui va se passer je
me pose comme ça sur le petit petit côté
pointu oui
ah oui alors attends je leur mets sur le
petit bout pointu et hop voilà ça fait
tourner la tête à toutes les commandes a
fait ça c'est très passionnant
alors si je le mets comme ça ils bougent
pas rire est il reste tranquillement
toujours sur la côte est alors si je le
mets comme ça rote tu vois il revient et
sans le petit bout pointu voilà il va
dans tous les sens c'est que mais
comment tu as fait ça c'est parce qu'on
le tue voix qui a le fond il ou non
oui on est lente et oui en réalité tu as
tu a percé le loeuff voilà un jeu les
vider oui alors je voulais faire gober
oui parce que je ne vote pas moins sont
pas les miens je les fais gober et puis
joly a rempli avec autre chose
cette cassette il répond je sais moi je
vais vous expliquer comment il l'a fait
parce que je connais son système en
réalité voilà regardez cet oeuf
c'est un oeuf tout à fait normal bon ici
il y a un trou que vous pouvez voir très
bien se trouve c'est tout con con bien
entendu qu'il a fait il a fait
exactement le même trou de l'autre côté
seulement il la bouche et après avec de
la paraffine ou avec de la colle ou avec
n'importe quoi d'ailleurs
alors voilà comment ça se passe vous
percez donc ce trou là et ce trou là
vous videz l'oeuf soit en legault banc
comme il l'a dit tout à l'heure soit en
soufflant dans l'un des tout ce qui
permet de vider complètement l'oeuf est
de salir la personne qui est en face de
soi absolument une fois que c'est fait
vous remplissez l'oeuf avec par exemple
du sable on pourrait utiliser aussi de
la limaille de fer mais c'est mieux
jack woodburn à deux pas de la limonade
de la limaille de frais bon alors vous
mettez du sable à peu près jusque là du
peu moins inquiet oui non pas tout à
fait la moitié
moi j'ai dit de la moitié est contre moi
je te suis ensuite vous versez toujours
par le trou qui se trouvent là un peu de
paraffine par exemple savez la paraffine
c'est ce que l'on met sur les confitures
pour fermer les couvercles et cela va
faire une sorte de magma qui va se
retrouver en bas et qui va faire un
poids et dans l'oeuf bon ça fait ça va
être lourd
ce qui fait que love se mettra toujours
dans la même position
bien entendu vous n'oublierez pas de
reboucher l'autre côté avec soin de
lacolle soit encore un peu de paraffine
ou de la cire également voilà comment on
fait et après c'est un oeuf magique
alors c'est un homme extraordinaire
vous le mettez dans n'importe quel sens
et hop il restera toujours debout ah
c'est christophe colomb avait connu ça
on n'aurait pas eu de problème
serait pas là on n'en serait pas là
voilà bravo à temps avant de sortir
oui fais moi une grimace en ont pas
encore des champions une police
aujourd'hui
fais moi le téléphone le téléphone je te
fasse qu'un téléphone jean rien n'avance
voilà je vais faire les téléphones
natation reggae bien autant là
maintenant à gbon mime recommençant non
vous pour commencer encore c'est la
dernière fois à j'aurais tout fait tout
fait j'y vais à l'eau à l'eau c'est ça
oui tu n'as pas honte
1 enfin pas tout à l'heure je m'en vais
en faire avec bell bell téléphone les
drones entraîner bien téléphone est
drôle il faut qu'on soit aussi bien
clermont c'est le point mais bon on peut
l'appeler tu te lèves téléphone qui
détermine la nappe et le téléphone
maintenant tu me fait faire des grimaces
et après j'ai l'air de quoi
d'un téléphone d'un téléphone où il
était salement mouvement exactement bon
aloi tous les trois je sais ce qui
m'attend c'est le bleu comme voilà bon
je commence comme d'habitude alors que
vous êtes surpris aujourd'hui je suis
une casserole
oui une casserole d'eau salée
les casseroles qu'on accroche dans les
cuisines et qu'on est convaincu qu on
brigue pour qu'elles brillent tu vois ce
que je veux dire il vient oui on peut
s'en servir dans un miroir d'ailleurs
quand elle est très propre la casserole
est bon alors je peux être en cuivre
d'aluminium en fer blanc et puis aux
barbes peut se servir de moi pour faire
des tas de choses des pommes de terre
sautées enfin n'importe quoi et tant
qu'il y aura des casseroles attentes et
la seule chose que je passais comme
accroche à la queue d'un chat un oui non
ça alors c'est pousse pousse une
poubelle belge sait pas ce qu'elle va
c'est à belle-beille magazine chat je
trouve que ça me va très bien je suis
gracieuse souples légères et les quand
je me promène silencieusement à travers
l'appartement
je ne fais pas de bruit je ne cache
jamais rien et quand on est gentil avec
moi j'ai mis un meuble audio sur vos
genoux jours
si vous me caresser doucement ça me
gratte un peu le dessus de ma tête oui
vous le promets je ne sortirai pas mais
glyphes mayas l'ont bien à moi à moi je
suis un cinéma un état bien entendu un
cinéma attention à un grand cinéma dans
une grande ville un gain sur un grand
grand boulevard dans lequel on joue de
grands films avec tes grandes vedettes
françaises et étrangères
alain delon anthony quinn on me schnerb
et le monde au de funes est en ce moment
on joue un film qui a un succès fou quoi
vous vous battez ou bousculer pour venir
chez moi oui et vous avez raison ça ça
en vaut la peine
voilà c'est tout en trichant une
casserole et un cinéma quel rapport
peut-il bien y avoir entre les trois
quel est le point commun une chatte une
que le cinéma il m'a dit que le cinéma
il y avait beaucoup de monde que c'est
un truc ça marche est un grand film mais
oui avec la casserole je verrai bien à
bas la chatte si ça marche ça marche ça
y'est milliyet
eh ben ça y est mes enfants une queue
bah voilà un lien a que de la casserole
là que de l'achat et la queue au cinéma
et ben voilà vous ne l'avez pas encore
xiam choléra et des formidables et je
crois je crois entre nous que nos
camarades qui nous regardant son sont
extrêmement forts aussi car il avait
trouvé
ah ben oui c'est qu'après ça vient jour
là c'est à toi mais bon c'est à moi
c'est bon c'est mon jeu assez noah fabry
soit demander quelque chose
qu'est ce que tu fais avant de commencer
notre jeu vous êtes une gratte wii fait
une gratte un peu mais où ça là là là
sur la droite la la wii la wii au oui
oui oui à un peu plus bah oui à la wii
ou ici là bah oui mais je veux que je
fasse tout dans cette émission c'est
extraordinaire ça va maintenant
et ça va travailler si ça va ça bon
alors voilà lui veut que je fasse de
grimaces et dont il faut que je te
graoui je ne demande que ça va s'arrêter
bon alors mon jeu cette semaine c'est
pas toujours le mot à deviner à bas prix
alors j'y vais alors tombé dedans à lyon
qu'est ce que j'avais fait de mon style
le voile a perdu ton crayon j'ai eu peur
après je l'aï perdue à un volet du
tableau alors c'est un mot en dix
lettres dit l'être dit ça y est on
commença alors la première lettre c 1 h
hhhh l'arabe alors après tu fais huit
petits points 8 titres aig qui
travaillent qui remplace à être bien
être 2 3 4 5 6 7 et enfin 8 et la
dernière lettre un t1 ptt tpt je me
demande ce que tu m'as encore préparer
là alors là tu poses des questions
c'est un animal à rehab a tout de suite
un message de ce qu'il en est avec moi
je suis pas sorti de la faire pour
autant alors c'est un animal qui a les
poils pour fou des poils on peut pour
appeler ça peut pas appeler ça des fois
c'est pas des noms mais voilà pourquoi
ils sont allés sont durs
bcd que des plumes ah non c'est pas des
plumes ne se sont pas des plumes pas des
plumes c'est un animal qui a une peau ou
alors tout simplement bah oui oui tony
allen
ah non il est pas tout lu je n'ai pas
tout nu au nom n'aurait pas tenu au nom
et ce qu'ils mangent de l'herbe
le pauvre n'ont pas beaucoup d'air non
ils mangent plutôt des de la viande non
non plus pas de viande pendant les
récrés activement ce poisson non non pas
de poisson pas de poisson les insectes
oui ah oui plutôt oui oui les insectes
et les uns c'est le tu que je te donne
la troisième lettre ça peut aider un peu
plus parce que j'ai un peu la wii lâché
j'avoue et vas-y alors la troisième
l'est c'est un air air voilà voilà
mais attends attends attends commençant
par and her ici non c'est un petit
animal sein d'un petit animal je trouve
comme une petite boule
oui il est très gentil oui il est mignon
aux yeux trop mignon oui il a des pics
et là des piques des failles traversé la
route qui se fait écraser bêtement par
des automobilistes
enfin ces principes là si bafa booth
moussu mais moi je pense à hérisson et
ben oui bah tu as deviné sahiri thierry
son pesant de 500 da hérisson à cheveux
deux eric 2 s o nt h1 eu de there in 2-0
nti raison puisque une chance de touques
encore et sans l'attaquant thomas iris
hommage aux héros verront les deux cas
on encore fait râble on a un contrat et
l'orthographe un l'orthographe
vous savez comment ça s'écrit hérisson
enfin h e et suffit tapas deux r1 alors
deux aces 1 au n
voilà comment on écrit hérisson bon bah
y'a pas il n'y a pas de géant
en bons ballons obama jacques auriac y
avait deux ipad 2 hervé herry son ya
deux aires nous passons pourquoi nos
âgées pas de chance hein
pourtant moi j'aime bien j'aime bien le
hérisson parce qu'il me ressemble un peu
oui c'est vrai il a l'air d'une grosse
boule on n'en voit pas se voir lire ici
d'abord parce que pendant la journée
ça reste souvent tranquille sans bouger
à l'ombre des buissons la tranquille ça
ne sort que le soir en plus ça tout
l'hiver s'adorent salle se réveille
qu'on printemps et tu sais de quoi
history ce hérisson un écoute at elle
dit à leurs maris stella des insectes
les flots et les moustiques des
mouchards et à oui bah c'est très utile
le hérisson car pour un jardinier c'est
aussi utile car atout ou un arrosoir
alors tu vois à sallanches qui ça écoute
je veut bien accorder comme ce qui
concerne les animaux de la forêt tu
connais beaucoup beaucoup de choses
poursuit su malheureusement
l'orthographe
alors tu vas me rattacher envers site ou
pas penser que ça c'est gentil de ta
part si c'est vrai j'en tire une
affluence record
j'ai comme belbel par exemple elle bruit
il s'appelle elle chante elle fait
[Musique]
mais si haut c'est très haut c'est très
con c'était chaud mais c'est pas un
défaut inigo ses tripes à tout en bas
mais la base y'a du breuil des flandres
gilbert lui rompu pour buhl attaques
connues
je n'en peux plus je suis décidé à me
gêne accomplir certaines mères
ces prix aussi très beau et très chaud
mais c'est pas un diplôme c'est très bas
tout entamé la base y'a du soleil de
plomb
hall est formidable c'est que j'ai mon
petit revolver a justement tu ferais
mieux de le cacher parce qu'on va avoir
des ennuis
qu'est ce qui se passe on se promène pas
avec un revolver comme ça devant des
amis un coût pourrait partir on serait
blessé avec toi tout tu ne connais rien
n'a rien d'une sais pas de quoi tu
parles
je suis une championne de tir mois à
monsieur oui oui mais comment depuis mon
séjour au mexique
je ne vous en ai pas parlé pour ne pas
vous inquiéter si je vous avais dit mes
chers amis je m'en vais pour plusieurs
mois dans la sierra madre qu'auriez vous
répondu oui - dieu sait pourtant oui je
voulais m'initier à l'existence
aventureuse des chercheurs or ces gens
là en vrac sont devenus mes amis je
souhaitais aussi contempler 2008 où ses
superbes paysages qui les westerns nous
aurons des familiers et comme dans
l'acien bram atteindre et chacun tire
son revolver à propos de tweed rien j'ai
pensé qu'il me fallait suivre l'exemple
de la population très rapidement je suis
devenue championne de dire oui
championne de la province de chihuahua
réalisant une remarquable performance à
battre un papillon en plein brouillard
le brouillard mexicain est difficile à
imaginer
et ceci est venu distance de 100 mètres
mais parfaitement comment on re ce
n'était qu'un exercice d'habileté
fabrice j'ai connu des moments de danger
l'ivresse au cours d'une chasse à l'ours
blanc dans la montagne aux environs de
mexico le monstre et est effrayant il
ouvrait une gueule des mesures et les
indiens qui m'accompagnait fille est en
cours
la dernière était là j'ai pris mon
énorme bête était à mes pieds déjà
réduites à l'état de tarp est bien
voyage oui oui mais tu connais ma
générosité j'en ai filmé diatement
cadeau au chef de l'expédition et pour
me remercier
ils m'ont emmené faire une excursion sur
sajoo que personnel je n'étais jamais
monté sur ce genre de bateau
cet abri c'est très curieux les voiles
sont faites en hâte avec des toiles
cousus sur des lattes de bon bout oh oui
oui s'amuse à essayer comme soit
comprise observatrice
oui je me suis habillé tout en voile
vitaux fabrice guy bitima bien c'est
bien on lui dit simon ailleurs les gens
qu'on m'explique l'homme et ses rangs
comex est cuit fait ça avec un ours
blanc oui bien entendu oui j'avais bien
nous recevions un ours blanc bonjour jeu
blanc lorsque je vais au mexique
oui jean moulin brise glaces flottantes
et la bri s'il te plaît j'ai deux pas
oui alors mon cher ami je te plaît de
bien écouter le son de ma voix
oui car c'est la dernière fois que tel
ou tel nom jeunes et adresserait plus
jamais de caprice notion je vais dire
adieu adieu au revoir à la prochaine
fois à la prochaine fois tiens prends
donc ton chapeau également voilà au
revoir non écoute tout concorde ou
smooth eu le temps de rire bêtement je
trouve ça normal toi rien ne vous a
frappé lorsque nous a raconté sa les
approches ok enfin le mexique 1 faute ou
non qu'on le fasse perdre l'habitude de
mentir comme ça ce plan raisonnable
avant il ne trompe personne a donc les
joncs que les gens que c'est en extrême
orient les gens sont des bateaux qui ça
va transporter les gens ou les
marchandises mais c'est typiquement
l'extrême orient
rien à voir avec le mexique
ce blanc vous voyez un ours blanc au
mexique avec le climat de là bas un
climat qui est plutôt plutôt chaud
plutôt plutôt sec nous tous dans
certains régions du mexique alors le
brouillard qui a peut-être un peu de
brouillard dans certaines régions du
mexique ça je veux bien croire n'est pas
là où elle était enfin c'est n'importe
quoi ça il faut lui faire perdre cette
habitude t'inquiète pas tout quand elle
reviendra très bientôt comme toujours un
petit coup de talon un petit coup deux
comme tout le monde j'ai pas fai ont
recouru jusqu'au bout des doigts le jeu
comme tout à l'heure 104 appareils neufs
magie le voilà attention l'oeuf magique
randell belle vraiment raconter des
histoires pareilles qui peut la croire
alors l'oeuf vous souvenez comment ça
fonctionne hop vous pouvez le faire en
creusant je vous le rappelle de petits
trous du sable au fond je souhaite
paraffine un peu de cire et le poids qui
se trouvent dans l'oeuf
il permet de revenir toujours à la même
position
voilà assez christophe colomb avait eu
cette offre quelle merveille tandis que
vous vous pouvez la voir très facilement
vous savez bien comment ça marche j'ai
besoin de recommencer bon alors à
bientôt
à très bientôt et amusez vous bien
demandez à votre moment de le préparer
cet oeuf attention sur la pointe hop au
revoir à bientôt
[Musique]